a successful vaccination campaign in
africa is a crucial part of eventually
drawing a line under the pandemic
worldwide
so far however only seven and a half
percent of the population has been fully
vaccinated according to the world health
organization one problem vaccines are
not arriving because rich countries are
hoarding them there's also logistical
difficulties with a large rural
population
in south africa scientists now want to
take the development of jabs into their
own hands so african countries hope to
become less dependent on vaccines from
industrialized nations as quickly as
possible
welcome to your covert 19 special i'm
daniel winter in berlin developing
nations have called for patent waivers
on covert 19 vaccines for months so far
without significant success now one
company is setting up africa's first
mrna hub in cape town with the goal of
copying the moderna vaccine adrian
creech reports
it's a first for the continent this
inconspicuous building in an industrial
area of cape town is the base for
africa's mrna vaccine technology hub
with vaccines in short supply in africa
the who and kovacs initiative led the
drive to set up a local technology
sharing platform that's one of the
positive legacies of covet we now in the
last eight months have seen this this
this massive funding available now for
biotechnology in south africa in cape
town and also in africa afrijin is the
company tasked with developing and
producing mrna vaccines these are
relatively new but highly effective
vaccines that so far only two major
companies have commercialized biontech
and moderna afrijin was counting on a
cooperation with modena the model was
that we will receive a technology
transfer turnkey technology transfer but
that didn't happen so the team now has
jumped in with our university partners
and the knowledge base in south africa
to develop our own backseat
one of the key partners is in
johannesburg the anti-viral gene therapy
research unit at whitwater's rand
university
they've been working on mrna technology
since 2015
as one of the only research units on the
continent they are now sharing their
skills and knowledge with efrigen
we have been able to take information
which is available in the public domain
to work out how the moderna mrna is
produced so we have the sequence and we
have the context of that sequence
which we've been able to reproduce but
of course
the purpose of that really is to use as
a reference
rather than as something which we want
to try and
use as a as a product
so we would like to develop our own
ideas and we are in fact doing that
already and compare that to the modern
vaccine back in cape town pietro
tablanche is still hoping modena comes
on board as this would speed up the
process moderna has announced a patent
waiver while the pandemic is still
ongoing but afterwards no
commercialization will be possible
without its approval
we would like to have a voluntary
license to be able to transfer this
technology to other lower middle income
countries to use the platform for other
vaccines hiv tb ebola flu this hub and
the capacity capability we're building
here
is is beyond covert
today most vaccines used on the
continent are important afrijin and its
partners aim to bring the first
homegrown products to market within
three years
and let's get more on this with petro
terblanch who you saw just featured in
our report just now and charles gore of
the medicines patent pool thank you very
much to you both for taking the time for
us today petro you
expect to get the first vaccines on the
market within three years based on on
this platform um if all goes according
to plan won't that be too late after all
other vaccine makers will have increased
their capacity massively by then
so daniel if you look at this in
isolation uh it may be and we hope that
it will be too late because we all want
this pandemic to go um if you just do
basic assessments of current the current
vaccine rates in africa it will take us
36 months at the current rate to reach
70 percent of the wh
goal for vaccination but the important
point is this fact see this mrna hub is
not an isolation it is a platform
which is built for future relevance to
establish and build capacity and
capability on this continent to be able
to in future
rapidly respond and also produce
vaccines that's relevant to the burden
of disease this is not only about covert
19 yes covet 19 is the catalyst and it's
driving the momentum
and the and the goal but it's more than
just covert 19. okay so it goes much
more beyond covid
charles how important are patent waivers
and technology transfer in providing
developing nations with vaccines
um patent waivers are something being
discussed at the moment at wto and
really that's for governments to decide
what they want to do
but
patents are important
patents
encourage innovation
but at the same time that's why we have
a licensing model that allows us to uh
use those patented um
discoveries and
in the mpp model to uh deliver them to
low and middle income countries in the
context of the hub
we as as uh petrosso um clearly said we
are hoping that we would get some uh
technology from moderna that we could
license in if that doesn't happen there
may be other technologies that we wish
to license in because the mrna field is
a rapidly developing field with
innovation happening all the time
it may be possible that the innovation
will come from south african
universities and we won't need to
license it in from
big companies in the developed world
but we need to be prepared for that and
then also importantly
once
petro and her team at afrigen have
developed the technology we then need to
license that out to other manufacturers
um throughout low and middle income
countries on turns that are that are
really promote public health because
that is what this is about right and
charles um they
there is the argument of course that
just opening up patents completely
making them free would deter the
industry uh from innovation so do you
agree with that sentiment
i i actually don't want to be drawn onto
onto whether uh patent waivers are right
or wrong as i say that's a government uh
decision and it's being debated at the
moment and it's also for industry to say
whether they'd be deterred by this but
we have to remember that
this is not only about patents it's also
about technology
there's actually no point having a
patent waiver if you don't know how then
to actually
use the technology
and some of this technology is very
complex and you do need that help so
it's actually both patents
and uh technology together and i don't
think those are both being discussed
together it's just the patent side of it
okay and petro uh just to be clear so
you would like moderna to give you their
technology or to license it to you um
but standing in your way are
shareholders and executives who say well
if we give you our technology for free
or at a discount that means you should
give away your vaccine patents as well
that you develop with this platform what
do you say to those people
so firstly we want freedom to operate
and we have not asked for a handout
we've asked for a negotiation and a
mutually beneficial voluntary license
agreement but the conditions will be
that for lowering middle-income
countries there has to be access for the
sake of public good in terms of african
we're a biotech startup company we are
putting efforts and energy and our
knowledge base with this fantastic
support we're receiving from all our
partners into this program we have a
vaccine facility that we are now
donating towards this program so i have
personally no problem for public good
to share in a sustainable manner the
intellectual property that we develop
okay thank you very much petro
terblanche and charles gore thank you so
much for joining us
now it's time to turn to our science
correspondent derek williams
if omicron is highly transmissible but
not very harmful will it outperform
other variants
delta outperformed earlier versions of
the virus so will omicron soon
outperform delta uh well this is pretty
theoretical territory but a lot of
experts say
that when postulating about covet 19
variants it's important
to uncouple the issues of increased
transmissibility
and virulence to some extent for a key
reason which is that
with all the variants detected so far
people can spread sars kov2 for days
before they begin to feel ill themselves
in fact that stealthy ability on the
part of the virus has fueled the
pandemic probably more than any other
factor so
although there's early evidence that
omicron hopefully seems to not cause
more severe disease on average than
other variants and quite possibly less
severe
there was no guarantee that it would um
evidence is piling up though
that omicron is very likely more highly
transmissible than other variants by
some expert estimates
those who get it
might pass it on to twice as many people
as those infected with delta it kind of
goes without saying that
transmissibility is a key factor in
whether one variant begins outperforming
others but the other central one at this
point is not virulence healthcare
officials say but
whether a new variant can overcome
existing immunity
delta for instance
can infect those who've been vaccinated
or who have recovered from covet 19
but not really that effectively and and
usually not for very long and
those patients generally have defenses
that mostly prevent severe disease and
and also curtail the number of people
that they can infect in turn
to spread effectively in a in a world
where a lot of people have immune
protection
new variants will have to evade it and
at this point at least omicron looks
like it's able to do that
better than previous variants but it'll
take time for the data to build up
enough
to provide a clear picture
with delta it took months
and that's all from us thanks for
watching
[Music]